joining us now is the CEO of AT&T
Communications John Donovan I don't know
what that title means but since we're in
the communications business at AT&T
I'm guessing John is my boss and John
joins us now
Pittsburgh native Notre Dame background
and joining us here for the AT&T Pebble
Beach pro-am if I said Pittsburgh could
win
now you're talking Steelers here John
whatever you like okay if the Steelers
could win another Super Bowl or Notre
Dame another national title
I think Steelers another Super Bowl and
the reason for that is we need to get
back on top Super Bowl count yeah we
have to go get another one
how many Super Bowls have you gone to
how many have I gone to probably 10
something in that range have you gone to
all the Steeler ones yeah Steelers make
you cry never never never Notre Dame
make you cry yeah when fights won Oh
that'll do it cuz it brings back all the
memories you know they flood back Oh
once were you there when Joe Montana was
there I was I was a freshman when he was
a senior ok and interestingly that was I
guess it was 1979 I was there with Bob
Golic Chris Haynes and Joe Montana on
draft day listen to the calls coming in
it didn't have the same process now the
phone would ring and say you ready we're
gonna take you the next round and then
they didn't it was some one of the most
fascinating things that I've ever done
in my life is to watch you remember Joe
Montana slid third round yeah third
round yeah so to watch the emotion of
him going through that so but I also had
to like wake up
Bob Golic at 7:30 in the morning to get
him to swim class and we were paired up
and yet because he you have to take
swimming class to get out of Notre Dame
weight and you got to take swimming yeah
we had to back then I'm not a young guy
dad I know but I why you swimming I
don't know it well you had to take PE
for a couple of semesters and one of the
things you was required was swimming I
guess they didn't want any of us
the hake and and so Bob was a senior had
put it off and so I was his neighbor and
I was a freshman and he weighed at that
time big for a linebacker 265 pounds and
he would take me there and you know
you're swimming and they say okay now
try to drown the other person it would
be a split instant and my head would go
for above the water to pressed against
the bottom of the pool because he didn't
float I mean he sank yeah it was fun
you mentioned though on the working
relationship you had a great week last
weekend and so I was gonna surprise you
with the Employee of the Month AT&T and
it says the best employee of the month
dan Patrick signed by John Donovan and
it's a February 8th 2019 what what I'm
looking at it looks like we spelled your
name wrong I'm sorry it's close close
enough yeah I'm alright with that yeah
no I guess cross it out okay what do I
get like with this like parking spot
another year another year doing this
yeah all right yeah take that
Dean Patrick you know Tom Brady doesn't
have employee of the month with the
Patriots my guess is it he'll be
eligible this month no he's no he's
never won employee of the week with the
Patriots in that amazing yeah I'm not
sure what it would take then after six
Super Bowls yeah who's the better
quarterback Bradshaw or breeding they're
just so different what I loved about
Bradshaw is he's the anti Brady he was
the gunslinger you know if when the
going got tough in the huddle he'd just
say run down the field I'll get it to
you yeah and he would throw it as hard
as he could and you got to love that you
know when you're winning on defense with
the play of defense and you see that but
you can't bet again you can't ever not
say that Tom Brady was six OOP
bull's eye there's a couple things I'm
going to ask you about first of all when
you get involved AT&T Pebble Beach
pro-am what is what is the goal of the
title sponsor well you you really have
to pull together a bunch of things that
are can be a little tricky and we take
it for granted the first thing is you
have to stay true to the purpose of the
tournament which is about the community
and so you can't get so caught up in the
celebrity and the shows and the
television and the winner and the trophy
and the purse you have to all the way go
back the the minute this tournament
tears down our folks start thinking
about next year is the money being
applied well is it getting to the right
people in the community you have to pull
that together the second dimension is
you really have to make sure the show
itself is good
you've got to recruit and have folks
calling the players getting them out
here reminding them what it's there for
and then for us it's one of our big
events where we bring a lot of customers
in so we we try to entertain our
customers and make it a showpiece for
the business itself and pulling all
those off is can be tricky also we're
talking to John Donovan the CEO of AT&T
Communications the future of TV sports
we saw the match you know made-for-tv
events yeah so Tiger versus Phil how
much more are we gonna see do you think
in the next couple of years I think it's
just the tip of the iceberg of you know
when you start to think about how all
that came together was on traditional
cable it was on bleacher report they
started to show the odds so we we really
went out trying to try something brand
new that hadn't been done before and
felt like there would be a good market
for that and so it wasn't perfect this
year we didn't get everything exactly
right but it was I think something we're
gonna try to do again repeat and see if
we can't find something there
what about gambling involved in it now
they the two players you know Phil and
Tiger we're gambling a little bit like
we're heading towards that but how when
is that happening do you think well I
think that we
we start the process with a removal of
some of the legal prohibition and then
everybody says well what does that mean
you know and I think there's been a lot
of hyperbole with sports owners saying
that's gonna change everything and it's
gonna you significantly and materially
change the value of franchises and it
might over time but in the sort short
run it's sort of trying to make social
dimensions where you have small wagers
amongst friends and it causes you to
watch parts of the game and notice
things that maybe the purists would
watch is it gonna make this foul shot
and you start to think about if I'm
gonna bet on whether you can make a putt
here I'm gonna have to know a lot of
things about you but I'm also gonna have
to know a lot of things about the hole
and is this the kind of thing you know
how do you deal with stress and so I
think the acuity with which people are
gonna have to do things in the future so
personally I don't think it's gonna be
you know about creating a whole new
genre of gamblers yeah I think it's
gonna be a social event and a little bit
of trash-talking amongst friends and
small betting at high velocity but also
being in the communications business at
AT&T and everything's on your phone
where are we headed with sports coverage
live events well I think that we're
moving to where a traditional view of
anything is lost and it's being replaced
with I need an experience like I need an
experience and it doesn't just involve
what's going on the event itself I need
a whole bunch of things around it
whether that's connections to friends
whether it's social whether it's the
gambling dimension whether it's the apps
the data so we're really trying to
tailor experiences and and I think that
that the tailored experiences are
challenging us to just get better at
what we do final question you could play
a round of golf at Pebble
uh-huh any current or former
professional athlete Joe green Mean Joe
green yeah cuz I did you know can he
play golf
I don't doesn't matter yeah when you
look there
a lot of the ex dealers their stories
are out there and you know him throwing
the ball in the stands the how he showed
up and intolerance for losing I just
want to hear his story and and I think
that would be a really good thing
because when I grew up it was right at
that time in that team and so I have
this this view of holding those folks up
on a pedestal so last week at the Super
Bowl I had a chance to meet Mel Blount
he looks like he could still play John
yeah but you keep Majan he was six foot
four he's playing defensive back back
when everybody was 511 right right and I
remember did he have his cowboy hat on
yes no he's got that black yeah you know
we were we were talking about some of
his matchups and I told him I met one of
the all-star receivers from his time
frame and the guy came up and he was
very proud of his accomplishments and I
said to him you might have done really
well in your career and you did but you
should feel great but you never caught
one pass on Mel Blount and he said
you're right that was a bad matchup for
me thank you for your support with the
show thank you for the Employee of the
Month even though it's misspelled it
doesn't matter because I know it came
from your heart yeah it's your dad yes
yeah yeah I just say quickly though that
that this tournament raised almost 13
million dollars last year and kind of
closing on on where you start it really
is a great honor for us to come out here
and serve the community the way we do
what shows because it's a first-class
run tournament and I always I tell these
guys about the magic of Pebble because
they'd never been here and then they got
here a couple of years ago and they go
we get it and we're proud to have you on
the team you're a great guy good human
being thank you you do great work thank
you John that's a make sure we record
that I'm gonna play that back to John
during my next contract that's a John
Donovan the CEO of AT&T Communications
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]